[Music]
even though the pandemic isn't
completely behind us travel is expected
to continue surging into the new year
the tsa says that air travel is up by
nearly double from a year ago regional
airlines say they're already
experiencing a pilot shortage and that
could affect the major airlines since
they hire from the regionals we have
almost 100 airplanes effectively
grounded right now we have to have a
higher supply of pilots and we just
don't have enough today and all of us
travelers could potentially feel the
effects by seeing fewer flight options
and even higher ticket prices
now all of these ripple effects have
brought a controversial 2013 airline
regulation back into focus it's called
the 1500 hour rule so what is it and why
is it relevant today i had to jump back
more than a decade to find the answers
[Applause]
on an ice cold night the flaming
wreckage of continental flight 3407. in
2009 a regional plane stalled in the air
and then crashed into a house killing 50
people outside of buffalo new york
investigators later found that the
captain's poor training was at fault
congress began searching for solutions
to prevent future pilot errors we do
need to make sure there's a standard of
safety
for every american and one of its
proposed reforms was the 1500 hour rule
the nickname came from the fact that it
would require aspiring pilots in the u.s
including co-pilots to have 1500 hours
of prior flight experience before taking
the controls of a passenger or cargo
plane that is a six-fold increase from
the previous minimum of 250 hours as wsj
reported at the time airline officials
warned that the rule would increase
costs for pilot training which would
aggravate the already dwindling supply
of commercial aviators leaving smaller
airlines understaffed and smaller cities
without essential air services but
congress was undeterred we've got to fix
these problems and it's going to take
both more hours and better quality and i
support any efforts that will get us
there at the order of congress the
federal aviation administration
implemented the 1500 hour rule in 2013.
even though there are some exceptions to
the 1500 hour rule for pilots with
certain kinds of degrees or training the
requirements are still high compared to
other parts of the world for perspective
pilots in europe and canada only have to
have two or three hundred hours before
they step into the cockpit so what
happened next as expected the rule added
years and tens of thousands of dollars
to the process of becoming a pilot in
the u.s and just months after it went
into effect airlines in the u.s faced a
pilot shortage leading some to cut
routes to smaller airports and even file
for bankruptcy the shortage led airlines
to pay pilots higher salaries and ramp
up partnerships with flight schools and
universities to improve the pathways to
the profession to this day there's a
dispute in the industry over whether the
rule has improved safety as you can
imagine the 1500 hour rule has remained
a sensitive point of contention when
republicans led an effort to revise it
in 2017 to expand service to smaller
airports democrats quickly shut down the
idea we're never going to give up
never as you never will give up
washington left the rule as is and
airlines scrambled to get new candidates
in the pipeline
then came the pandemic which presented
unprecedented challenges for the airline
industry when covet hit people stopped
traveling altogether and airlines were
incentivized to offer pilots early
retirements that's because in order to
take advantage of government aid through
the cares act companies weren't allowed
to furlough workers at the four biggest
u.s airlines more than 4 400 pilots
opted to depart last year and when
vaccines arrived we all rushed to snap
up our tickets as travel takes off again
airlines are scrambling to keep pace
with the summer surge after crunching
the numbers consulting firm oliver wyman
says that the u.s could face a shortage
of 7 000 pilots by 2025. to understand
how this will impact airlines and all of
us travelers i called a partner at that
consulting firm jeff murray who happens
to be a former pilot himself and if
you're retired you can't come back and
get your seniority and your route is
that right that is absolutely right so
the the airline pilot profession is a
seniority based profession they would
have to come back as a junior pilot that
means a co-pilot a first officer working
weekends earning first officer pay yeah
forget it exactly no way they're going
to come back exactly so it was a really
unique challenge that um that the
charisma put in place as you can imagine
airlines need a huge amount of pilots
and they've embarked on a hiring spree
the big u.s carriers delta southwest
united and american are on track to hire
13 000 pilots this year and next but
here's the thing the majors frequently
hire from the regionals these are
companies whose official names are
endeavor air and psa airlines but that
commonly fly under names like delta
connection and american eagle and the
regionals say they're already
experiencing a pilot shortage they're
the first point of pain with respect to
the pilot shortage so they will feel it
first this is what a regional airline
executive recently said on an earnings
call the shortages of pilots driven by
the federally mandated 1500 hour rule
and now exacerbated by early retirements
that the major carriers will require our
largest focus over the near term and if
airlines cannot get the pilots they need
how will travelers how will all of us
consumers feel the effects so we're
going to see it through reduced
schedules so you're still going to be
able to get where you want to go but you
likely won't have the flexibility that
you've had historically and you're
probably going to be paying a little
more plus if there's bad weather jeff
says airlines won't be able to recover
as quickly as they usually do since
their staffs aren't as big okay so on to
the big question will the 1500 hour rule
ever change everyone i talked to for
this story supporters and critics say
it's unlikely that it will ever just be
done away with but some airline
executives hope the faa could provide
more exceptions to it like allowing
highly relevant simulator hours to count
toward the 1500 hours and they say
improving government aid options would
help aspiring pilots the problem to
become a pilot particularly at the 1500
hour rule is you need to spend 150 000
and that's typically not eligible for
government loans so creating ways that
they can finance and fund
their ability to get the requisite
training is really the foundation and i
think it's the only way we're going to
solve this problem for small communities
because i expect it's going to get worse
before it gets better when i reached out
to the faa for comment they sent me a
press release about the rule from 2013.
some believe it would take an act of
congress to make changes
so do you think congress and the faa
should revisit the 1500 hour rule drop
me a line in the comments below and if
you liked this story and thought it was
informative please hit subscribe so you
can join me as i cover more news that's
impacting our lives
safe travels